gleich alles sehen wenn ich in der zu
hause bin oh mein gott ich glaub ich hab
den hexenturm gefunden hey leute und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
vom mega projekt eigentlich solltet ihr
jetzt schon mit 45 weitere folgen
gesehen haben
allerdings ist meine aufnahme abgestürzt
bz pcs abgestürzt und meine tastet die
spur hatte ich zwar noch gerne abspielen
aber das mit euch nichts weiß nur meine
stimme ist und kein bild und nichts park
und aufgenommen es freue ihn wieder
anwesend bei mir hat mal die folgerung
aus gesehen das waren 50 minuten
insgesamt leide in einem stück hoch 13
folgen oder so ich muss man ein paar
damit dass sich nicht allzu viel
parallel verschiebt und ich habe sowieso
schon genug 50 minuten folge macht das
nichts aus
komplettpaket wollt könnt ihr das auch
einfach beides park dann gucken bevor
jetzt jemand sagt du hast ja hier
vier spitzhacke und wirklich alles nein
habe ich nicht gezählt aber als
entrüstung ich habe auch hier kompakt
bin dabei mein generate zu machen und
wollte jetzt mehr und defizite richtung
gehen also wie general electric fördert
mail twitter und jetzt will ich erstmal
bei kunduz jahr gehen und das bin ich
vielleicht holt mich einfach ein
ja klar ich wollte anwendern mit gehen
das ist dann vielleicht ein spannender
wenn wir schon zu zweit auf eine kann es
auch zu zweit machen ich schmeiße noch
stellen bisschen zeug was zu moment habe
raus damit wir auch gleich loslegen
können moment müssen hier eisen compact
oper kämen komplett gerade gemachten
welt das ist ja ein bisschen
kontraproduktiv ach was das bisschen
nacht damit du hast ja auch ding ding
ding zauberstab herzens das ist so ja
klar ja genau ich kann hier ein bisschen
losgehen und abziehen mal also ich mich
beschützt ich keine sorge dass du nicht
gleich irgendwie kapierst du hin zum
vertrieb macht es noch vorsichtig reaper
keine panik bei kripo diese noch ganz
süß eigentlich mit 1000 zauberstäben ich
weiß nicht was alles mitnehmen das ist
so so köppels den ruin mäßig zeigt klar
besser nicht reingehen medikamenten
reingehen und einfach nur solche ruinen
quasi hier sind über kisten komisch
jetzt noch ein stück weiter düster wir
sind echt komische du musst mir dann
aber deine koordinaten sein damit ich
weiß wo du bist
ich gehe noch mal schnell ein paar
fackel mit meier nicht ich sagte ihm
gleich die koordinaten kanzlerin die
richtung kommt einfach so ein bisschen
facetime übrigens nicht am start weil
der akku auflädt eventuell nachher
wieder und erwiesen aber viele mob das
macht nichts hier macht das nix ich bin
ein normaler mensch ja was bin ich dann
helfen kann
ich bin ein bonus solar helbras bisschen
zauberer du guckst du siehst die welt
durch die rosarote pink oder rote peking
gibt sich rosarote pinkl genau oder rote
sollen so ein gelber bienenstock
dingsbums habe ich mag einen kescher ja
das kann ich dann gleich machen die kann
man gerne teilen wenn die bienen aber es
sehr zeitaufwendig habe ich gehört die
zu machen regte züchten und mit ihnen
bringt mit bienen achter ganz später
fiel sachsendruck sammer wo alles rein
fast schon sehr nützlich eigentlich
spielt sie mitnehmen sollte neuen
zauberstab erstmal nicht aber ein abbau
zuständig kann man mit
den verwandelte server starb dingen sind
und ein bisschen kosmetik austauschen
kann
du fragst jetzt höre ich mit 56 koppelt
somit damit ich schon erste mit mehr
abbauen kann aber dass es gleich gut
den einen tausch sauerstoff hab ich
dabei dann die slots obwohl genau ich
hab ja auch noch hier
das peg peg hier übrigens war ich schon
in der höhle dings und habe eine menge
team geholt
bla bla so ganz viele sachen halt na ja
gleich alles sehen wenn ich wieder zu
hause bin oh mein gott ich glaub ich hab
zum hexenturm gefunden thomas soja kann
ich hoch fliegenden zeug holen
hier wollen liegende burg klinke burg
altena weiß wo du bist ich glaub du bist
dann richtung koordinaten sachen den
koordinaten xs wörtlich schreibt in
chats ist dann wahrscheinlich -
irgendwas war so sieht genau 30 700 30
und 300 200 ok ich finde mal hoch und da
viele mops ich glaube da waren wir schon
derweil schon mit cash oder so weil hier
stehen wobei diese kescher und alles
klar wird sicher toll und noch nicht
ausgeleuchtet war ein diamant blogs in
seiner fliegen festungs ein diamant
lockeren wenn wir da noch nicht drin
warnt setzt diamant burg abkassieren
neuen diamant meinte einsacken
endlich ist natürlich cool aber ich
glaube bei den koordinaten bruders dabei
schon mit cash und mit simon
die prognosen sind online trainings auch
gefertigt oben also die sache jetzt auch
einfach dass das so ein bisschen blöd
weil ihr alle so krass fiel und erkundet
einfach mal alles aber so viel ist das
gar nicht was wir da machen und ich gehe
mal rum und will auf entdeckungstour
gehen und erfahren
er muss ein stückchen weiter weg gehen
haben wir schon ein bisschen gespielt
aber wir haben schon wissen die gegen
der kunde das ist klar
ja das sieht so aus jetzt warte ich
schon ich habe von den schon drei bühnen
prinzessin ich hab gerade auf dem weg in
der wüste diese bienen dinge abgebaut
waren sieben prinzessinnen drin oder so
die kenne ich dich auch mal dann müsste
es aber schon besser gehabt haben die
abzubauen
jaja hatte ich auch damals bei fiete
wies so damals an damals nämlich die
aktionäre von 70 platz gemacht hat
absolut nichts von dem ort gemacht ja
das haben wir auch die ganze zeit gesagt
dass wir das beste machen wollten weil
wir uns erstmal ausbauen wollte
wenn das jetzt auch noch kein haus
geholt hat kein haus aber dafür habe ich
halt anderes zeug was besser als ein
haus ist ja wir wollten uns halt er fünf
wochen verfolgt und autor spinnen und so
das macht gar nichts in sachen sind
hierbei der daran mag bestimmt schon
eingeschwommen ja hier sonnig wir
könnten in richtung gehen wo halt noch
keiner war wieder da war mir schon da
waren schon das war folge 18 bei mir
alles wieder drin waren ja gut sein dass
nach links weiter hinten sind schon
weiter gegangen ich würde nach rechts
weiter hinten gehen die kef gesagt aber
schon aber ich glaube nicht so weit wenn
man rein und da so eine ice festung
können uns anschauen was ist das schiff
das sind schriftlich klocke wasserpreis
schon ob man hier waren überall schon
welche acht hatte sich in diamant
gemacht er jetzt auch noch und
urkomische ich fliege mal hoch zudem
dingen guck mal was drin ist zudem cash
als heute zu den meist verfallen wie
viel verlangt ist sich ein jetpack zu
machen
jetpack kostet es geht relativ schnell
eigentlich aber du brauchst dafür ein
bisschen koffer unser zeug ganz
auswendig weiß ich leider auch nicht
mehr also ein bisschen was braucht schon
das ist gut das brauchst du auch so ich
habe jetzt mal ein bisschen lauter
gedreht damit mir einige blabla hier
hier sind 100 verfolgte ich sehe schon
wieder kopper habe ich ein unterwasser
anmaßt du kannst nie doch ganz ehrlich
das finde ich unter wasser ist eine
festung unter wasser so dass soja das
einfach wo ihnen ist jetzt drin
ich sehe den fall sehr ernst und ich
find's einfach mal durch einsammeln noch
mit einem wenn ich schon mal hier bin
du kannst machen aber unter wasser ich
muss einfach nur zum start eines drauf
klickt chance ganz abgebaut also
vorteilen scheiß ich unter wasser bonn
sinnvoll stressig diesen ball kammer so
kann 15 black rose unter wasser geht ich
genferin nach einklicken zauberstab
drauf muss nicht mit der spitzhacke
machen was ist das hier für baseball
hätten manche keine ahnung das geld oft
geil aus weiter möchte irgendetwas jetzt
finden wo ich so sagen konnte haye
das habe ich gefunden was ist denn das
kann zu einem raum finden kannst du
sagen hey ich hab ein baum gefunden
gut bestückt mit ganz groß zudem links
hin zu den sie aber der baum der war
echt cool recht cool also ist nichts
drin außer wolle irgendwie ich wohne
baum den luftballons sondern wir wissen
wolle einlaufen die kamera verwenden
erste luftballon dass da hat er sich
auch schön aus
ja aber ich meine zum einsammeln das
haben jetzt eine höhle solches defizit
nicht groß aus obwohl hier hier lächeln
ich schon wieder diese ganzen ärzte
lokal das riesige hülle das aber
zusammen reingehen kann ich machen
moment ich habe aber soviel bescheidene
prinzessin durch ein paar von den bienen
weg braucht ihr nicht wahrscheinlich
alle macht den etat ist voll das ist
natürlich jetzt klug ich brauche immer
noch redstone ich hab gerade steckt
voller gefahren den ballon ganz kurz
rein bin und ich brauche mal aufs tor
wahrscheinlich gibt es und was drin in
der höhle die komische dass sich immer
weiter raus komme aus der ölaktien die
ganze woche liegt jetzt am boden vom
meer am meeresgrund alte ordnung ausgang
scheiße muss man auch ein bisschen sagen
wo du hingehst richtung zu dem baum bist
ich glaube gerade zurück zu dir so ein
bisschen den urlaub statt der den
wellpoint ach so verdammt ich hab gar
kein weg punkt gemacht so stadtnähe ich
hatte ich habe bei der stadt den
wegpunkt gemacht aber das problem ist
halt der ist schon zwei mal wieder reset
wollen kanal wieso ich habe keinen plan
schon zweimal setzten einige beide bei
der links im mai bei dem luftballon bei
den schloss da weiß ich wo ich nach
hause muss meine koordinaten sind
- 1300 wahrscheinlich dann simply wait
for me förderverein wohl eher lästig
sondern langweilig verfasst hast wohl
angst ich glaube die ganze ressourcen
das was mit heimischen auch nicht dass
man die ganzen bienenstöcke so stehen
brauche ich nicht ich möchte jetzt auch
nicht ablehnen dort diamanten geschenkt
und so was alles aber hallo wir teilen
einfach das zeug aus dem fitness als ich
und simon und käppchen langgeht büßten
auch in der festung eine insel drin
waren haben wir einfach den diamant blog
geteilt durch 3 hat jeder drei gekriegt
genau kann mir neuen diamanten
ausgerichteter drei kriegt dann noch
brunnen gefunden in brunnen sind auch
diamanten drin meinte weise
manchmal und den gab es dann auch und
wenn ich hatte meine ich hab eine glücks
spitzhacke sohn der band bloc finden im
brunnen einen einzigen ein einziges erz
ich baue das ab dann kann seine vier
diamanten ausblocken dass ich gut so ich
hab ich jetzt gefunden ich bin kanadier
habe ich gesagt ist groß ja dieser vor
groß aus wenn du davon aus rein
kunstvoll große löcher vorne ja davon
ist symptom einer forderung eingehen was
war schon drin war nicht drin aber das
in kisten trinke
man kann auch zu finden ich kann der
tiere schätzt hochfliegen gucken was
drin ist obama gummitieren wird überall
es ist bitter für die ganzen kannst du
dich - hier sogar obwohl er laufen
mal gucken was hier so alles drin ist
oder ich kann auch aus der ferne abbauen
übrigens es gibt experten aber keine
finanziellen sollen passt auch irgendwie
feuer oder so dass die spieler hier
verbrennen kannst dass wir direkt
gebratenes fleisch neuerdings auf ihr
mops auf schlaf ich leide ich
mitgenommen hat keine macht ich hab die
alle verbraucht für meine die wand finde
spitze gar nicht selber gekommen
das bringt den quecksilber ach so dass
christ aus den blumen da unten die
braucht man eventuell für element
verzauberungen ich habe mir die auch
jetzt eigentlich gut von dem baum also
dringend brauchen durchs netz aber ich
hatte jetzt hier ständig höher mal
gucken der kiste auch hier drinnen brot
und eine schüssel und reingelegt links
links wo reingelegt und in dem raum
sitzt die quiksilver dingsbums ach so ja
gut sagt dann ein